[Música]
son las 8 y 30 de la noche en bogotá
quito y lima continuamos en directo
américa edición nocturna y seguimos
repasando los principales hechos del día
les agradecemos su sintonía y vamos con
los titulares de esta jornada
tras una reunión mediada por el
secretario general de la otan jens
stoltenberg el gobierno turco levantó el
veto a la adhesión de finlandia y suecia
a la alianza transatlántica se espera
que el miércoles en medio de la cumbre
de la otan en madrid los estados
miembros hagan la invitación formal
analizamos en esta emisión
jornada histórica para colombia la
comisión de la verdad entidad que nació
de los acuerdos de paz con la extinta
guerrilla de las farc presenta su
informe final tras más de tres años de
investigaciones el presidente electo
gustavo petro aseguró que con la verdad
del país no busca venganza sino avanzar
hacia la paz
y se conmemora el día del orgullo lgtb
temas en el mundo y pese a que los
coloridos desfiles inundaron las calles
de numerosas ciudades la situación en
estambul es contraria el gobierno
mantiene una dura política de represión
y califica a los integrantes de esta
comunidad de terroristas e inmorales
[Aplausos]
[Música]
damos inicio en la capital española
donde tras horas de reunión turquía
levantó el veto que mantenía sobre la
adhesión de suecia y finlandia a la otan
el encuentro estuvo mediado por el
secretario general de la alianza
transatlántica jens stoltenberg y la
decisión se produjo luego de que los
gobiernos de helsinki y estocolmo se
comprometieron a levantar el embargo de
armas a turquía ya luchar con más fuerza
contra el terrorismo pues ankara los
acusaba de dar refugio a combatientes
kurdos a los que consideran terroristas
para analizar esta información
conectamos con iván catón él es profesor
universitario analista internacional y
experto en geopolítica bienvenido a
france 24 la cumbre de la otan inicia
mañana en madrid cuáles son los
principales retos de este encuentro
pero el principal reto que tiene la otan
que es la adaptación que desde ahora se
está definiendo como un mundo nuevo y
una proyección a ese mundo que está por
venir a lo que yo robert kaplan de aoma
un mundo de anarquía comparativa y donde
la otan que ha venido asumiendo roles
que pertenecen a naciones unidas se ve
en un claro y pleno desafío con rusia en
este nuevo entorno que tenemos a partir
de la invasión rusa y ucrania el 24 de
febrero del presente año bueno y ahora
sin el veto turco cuál es el proceso que
deben seguir suecia y finlandia cuando
podríamos verlos como miembros de la
otan
de hecho ya soy sin finlandia venían
teniendo un acercamiento con
con colo está quizá será más el
procedimiento de la aceptación formal
pero ha sido notoria la participación y
el acercamiento de suecia en finlandia
con notan desde hacía un buen tiempo
ahora el veto de turquía mantenía
cerrada la posibilidad de que tanto
suecia como finlandia ampliarán las
fronteras de la otan con rusia a más de
3000 kilómetros y que esto evidencia que
la visión estratégica de que tenía la
otan hace 10 años
cambias radicalmente que lucía pasó de
ser una sociedad y un amigo en aquel
momento en la última reunión que se
sostuvo hacer un evidente enemigo
y en términos prácticos que aportan
estas naciones a la alianza
transatlántica suecia y finlandia
sobre todo digamos invita a su de
finlandia su experiencia en cuanto a su
ejército en una zona
digamos muy difícil de poder mantener
vigilancia que es lo que se ha estado
planteando ese si finlandia tiene una
experiencia en este clima tan frío lo
mismo swayze pero también tenemos que
ver que el ingreso de eso es en
finlandia lo que hace es
darle más vida a una institución que el
presidente macro nada va que estaba
cerebral no cerebralmente muerta y que
el presidente trump también la daba
prácticamente por liquidar hemos visto
que la invasión de rusia a la otan ha
hecho revivir a una organización que se
suponía que no tenía razón de ser porque
su creación en el año
1940 pues para contener la expansión de
la unión de repúblicas socialistas
soviéticas y estaba diseñada para un
entorno de guerra fría no para un mundo
del siglo 21 con desafíos distintos a
los cuales para los cuales la misma fue
creada señor gastón a usted muchas
gracias por su análisis y por
compartirlo con nosotros en france24
en ucrania el ministerio del interior
aseguró que no hay sobrevivientes bajo
los escombros del centro comercial que
fue impactado por los dos misiles rusos
en la ciudad de crem en chuck las
autoridades locales han informado al
menos 18 civiles fallecidos aunque
consideran que el número podría ser
mayor el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski pidió a naciones unidas que
designe un enviado especial para
investigar los hechos
y una triste declaración no hay
supervivientes bajo los escombros del
centro comercial en kremenchug dijo el
ministro de interior ucraniano de
momento se tiene constancia de al menos
18 fallecidos 36 desaparecidos y 59
heridos entre las más de 1000 personas
que se encontraban en el interior del
centro comercial durante el ataque con
misiles sin embargo es posible que el
número de víctimas mortales sea aún
mayor
sugiero que las naciones unidas- envíen
un representante especial del secretario
general de la onu o una comisión
plenipotenciaria al lugar de este acto
terrorista en kremenchug para que la onu
pueda averiguar de forma independiente
toda la información y comprobar que
efectivamente se trata de un ataque con
misiles rusos
los residentes de kremenchug visitaron
un memorial improvisado
contribuyendo a una creciente colección
de flores peluches y velas esta ciudad
industrial que alberga el mayor depósito
de petróleo de ucrania ya había sido
objeto de varios ataques aéreos desde la
invasión rusa ucrania el pasado 24 de
febrero pero los residentes dijeron que
los ataques anteriores no habían
afectados zonas civiles algo que los
hace pensar que ningún lugar en ucrania
es seguro ahora
quería salvar a mis hijas así que
vinimos aquí a kremenchug hace tres
semanas pensé que mis hijas estarían a
salvo aquí pero me equivoqué y
ucrania culpo a rusia de haber atacado
con misiles este centro comercial moscú
respondió diciendo que había golpeado un
depósito cercano de armas
estadounidenses y europeas
desencadenando una explosión que provocó
el incendio en el centro comercial ayer
todos los medios occidentales explotaron
con vídeos de crimen chuck mostraban
imágenes de un centro comercial en
llamas y acusaban al ejército ruso de
bombardear la infraestructura civil el
ministerio de defensa ruso explicó muy
claramente lo que realmente sucedió el
ejército ruso bombardeo un hangar donde
se habían traído armas y municiones
estadounidenses y europeas y como
resultado de la detonación en un centro
comercial vacío que estaba al lado se
incendió
pero ucrania aseguró que ese almacén
estaba en desuso y no podía calificarse
como objetivo militar
vamos a américa colombia vivió un día
histórico pues la comisión de la verdad
organismo creado a partir del acuerdo de
paz de 2016 para conocer la verdad sobre
el conflicto armado presentó su informe
final con recomendaciones para el
posconflicto el texto no es vinculante
pero si se considera una guía para
esclarecer la verdad histórica y hacer
justicia luís muñoz periodista de france
24 nos amplio los detalles
nueva jornada histórica en colombia la
comisión de la verdad surgida tras los
acuerdos de paz entre el estado y la
guerrilla de las farc en 2016 ha
presentado su informe final después de
tres años de trabajo y más de 30.000
entrevistas con víctimas lo ha hecho en
este teatro jorge eliécer gaitán
acompañado de víctimas también de
actores armados y es un relato una ayuda
para entender las dinámicas del
conflicto colombiano en los últimos 50
años el acto lo ha dirigido el padre de
rucks el presidente de esta comisión que
ha señalado que de todas las víctimas
que ha tenido el conflicto en colombia
si se hiciese un minuto de silencio
pasarían 17 años también ha socializado
los hallazgos las recomendaciones
hallazgos como que las principales
víctimas han sido los civiles y
recomendaciones como que hay que caminar
hacia una paz grande en un llamado al ln
y a otras disidencias que si no se va
hasta hacia esta paz podrían revivir el
conflicto también el acto ha participado
el presidente electo gustavo petro
ovacionado quien ha dicho que va a
llevar estas recomendaciones que las
vale el primero y que luego las va a
llevar a todo el territorio y han habido
también abucheos para el presidente aún
en servicio iván duque que no ha acudido
a este evento para terminar destacar que
ahora se inician dos meses de
socialización del informe y después un
comité de seguimiento de siete personas
durante los próximos siete años va a
incidir en la importancia al presidente
de aplicar estas recomendaciones que
salen hoy del informe de la comisión de
la verdad de colombia'
las autoridades de texas se elevaron a
51 el número de migrantes que
fallecieron dentro de un camión
descubierto que fue ubicado en una vía
de la localidad de san antonio los
migrantes perdieron la vida a causa de
las altas temperaturas a las que fueron
expuestos se trata de 39 hombres y 12
mujeres hay varios arrestados que según
los primeros informes pertenecerían a
una red de traficantes que transportan
migrantes de méxico y centroamérica
hacia eeuu
entre los muertos están dos hondureños y
siete guatemaltecos
vamos ahora a francia porque por primera
vez en la historia una mujer fue elegida
como presidenta de la asamblea nacional
estamos hablando de israel upyd diputada
de la alianza juntos del presidente
emmanuel ma con la funcionaria es una
abogada penalista de 51 años que viene
de una familia de origen judío y estuvo
al frente del ministerio de los
territorios de ultramar cargo que
abandonó precisamente para su
candidatura a la presidencia de la
asamblea convive encabezar al
legislativo más fragmentado desde
comienzos de la quinta república
francesa
y ahora vamos a turquía hace una década
el gobierno del presidente de reye tayip
erdogán era conocido en el mundo por ser
islamista y conservador pero tolerante
durante los primeros 13 años de su
mandato estambul se llenaba en junio
para la celebración del día del orgullo
lgtb temas ahora sin embargo la
represión contra el colectivo es total y
el ejecutivo los cataloga de terroristas
e inmorales en el siguiente informe de
nuestro corresponsal adrià rocha y de
albertina ya veremos las dificultades
que deben sufrir los integrantes de esta
comunidad
desde hace 7 años el gobierno de turquía
tiene prohibida la marcha del orgullo
sin embargo este año la comunidad lgtb
más intentó llevarla a cabo pero la
policía de estambul atacó e impidió la
celebración
de una mujer transexual que lleva
luchando contra esta represión toda su
vida señala que los ataques del gobierno
de recep tayyp erdogán son cada día más
fuertes
primero nos obligan a prostituirse y
después nos llaman inmorales pero quién
es el inmoral
quien no se nos da educación ni el
derecho a trabajar ni el derecho a vivir
quién es el inmoral aquí el sistema no
las mujeres transexuales
cuando erdogán llegó al poder en 2003 el
gobierno turco mostró una actitud
tolerante con la comunidad sin embargo
en 2015 desde que el presidente salió
con un partido ultranacionalista la
retórica cambió podridos y terroristas
es la etiqueta que el gobierno turco le
ha dado al colectivo
en turquía cualquiera que vaya en contra
de las políticas o el discurso general
del gobierno es considerado un
terrorista o un inmoral o alguien
financiado por un país extranjero
en turquía volvió el miedo a ser parte
de la comunidad lgbt más que es que una
joven transexual detenida hace dos meses
por la policía sin motivo fue víctima de
violencia en la comisaría aún recuerda
los golpes y las agresiones
tengo miedo cuando salgo a la calle
camino con un spray de pimienta en la
mano si alguien me rosa me asusto
muchísimo miro constantemente a mis
espaldas es muy difícil
tengo 25 años y nadie en mi vida me
había pegado
sandro no hay muy mal
en el intento de la marcha del orgullo
en estambul la policía detuvo a más de
350 personas pero pese a los insultos la
represión los encarcelamientos y la
violencia la comunidad promete seguir
luchando por su visibilidad
así finalizamos esta emisión de directo
américa aquí en france 24 a ustedes les
agradecemos su sintonía y los invitamos
a continuar con nosotros que ya llega a
herminia fernández con toda la
información de nuestra red de
corresponsales en el mundo feliz noche
para todos
[Música]